الثالث والعشرون من يوليو تموز الماضي في
سماء سوريا تقترب مقاتله روسيه وفق الجيش
الامريكي من طائره امريكيه مسيره من نوع
ام كيو 9 تضيقها وتطلق مشاعر مضيئه من
نقطه تعترض مسار المسير مباشره ومن مسافه
امتار قليله لتصيب احداها مروحه الطائره
المسيره وتلحق بها اضرارا بالغه حادثه من
بين اخريات تكررت دفعت وزير الدفاع
الامريكي لدعوه القياده الروسيه للتاكد من
انها تصدر توجيهات لقواتها لما سماه
الالتزام بقوانين السماء دعوه تعكس حجم
التوتر الذي اضحت الاجواء السوريه مسرحا
له
فثلاثه ايام بعد الحادث قال مركز المصالحه
الروسي في سوريا ان طائره مسيره تابعه
للتحالف الدولي الذي تقوده الولايات
المتحده اقتربت بما ينذر بالخطر من طائره
عسكريه روسيه من طراز سوخوي 34 في يوم
واحد وفق المركز سجلت ثمن حالات انتهاك
لبروتوكولات تفادي التصادم لثلاث طائرات
مسيره امريكيه في منطقه التنف وبالمجمل في
حصيله شهر يوليو الماضي لوحده تحدث المركز
عن نحو 300 تجاوز امريكي لبروتوكولات منع
التصادم ونحو 23 مواجهه خطيره هذا العام
من طيران التحالف مع الطائره الروسيه في
سماء سوريا بالمقابل في السادس من يوليو
تموز الفائت افادت القوات الجويه
الامريكيه من خيرات طائره روسيه في مسمته
سلوكا غير امن وغير احترافي اثناء
مشاركتها في مهمه ضد تنظيم الدوله في
الاجواء السوريه وتحدث مسؤول امريكيون عن
وجود شركات جويه روسيه امريكيه في الاجواء
السوريه في يوليو الماضي نحو ست مرات خط
عدم الاشتباك بين الجيشين في سوريا لتجنب
الاخطاء بالمواجهات غير المقصوده دفع
البلدين للاعلان في تشرين الاول اكتوبر
عام 2015 عن اتفاقيه لمنع التصادم بين
الطائره الروسيه والامريكيه في الاجواء
السوريه تتضمن قواعد وقيودا يجب على اطقم
الطيران اتباعها بالاضافه الى انشاء حلقه
اتصالات ارضيه بين الجانبين في حال تعطل
الاتصالات الجويه وان تحرص الطائرات في
الجانبين على الحفاظ على مسافه امنه تتهم
روسيا واشنطن بالقيام برحلات جويه غير
قانونيه في سوريا وتفعيل طيارها انظمه
الاسلحه عند الاقتراب من الطائره الروسيه
بينما يتهم المسؤولون الامريكيون الطيارين
الروس باستخدام اساليب غير مهنيه واستفزاز
طائرات التحالف الدولي خلال القيام
بعمليات ضد تنظيم الدوله
[موسيقى]